With the Central Limit Theorem, things become really easy.
Take a coin flip. There is a true probability p for the coin.
Now we know that we sampled the coin N times and compute from it
our empirical mean using the formula you well know.
That it's well true that it could easily happen that p doesn't end from µ
and that's because flipping the coin number of times is a stress and estimate of a true probability p.
Now whole likely our estimates, so suppose this is a true p and I gave you three possible µ.
This one, this one, and one out here, and I put a little check marks underneath.
Check the box that is the most likely µ you might observed,
if p is a true probability using our statistical estimator.
And of course, it's near this one.
If it the most likely one will repeat itself and the further out you are,
the less likely is to have a sample that it gets you this far out.
And now, we'll be using the Central Limit Theorem.
For large N, say N large N=30, we know that the distribution of µ you might observe is Gaussian.
For any value here, let's call this one a. The chances that we observed in µ that's smaller than a
is the same as the surface area and then the Gaussian over here.
There's a trick you haven't seen but the probability is driving any µ
is at least in the limit given by the height of this Gaussian.
So for any value a, we can compute a probability that µ becomes smaller than a.
And by symmetry, for any value of b, it's is equally away from p as a as on the left side of p,
they can do exactly the same thing.
Now, where does the 1.96 come from? and here's the trick, 1.96 marks the 95% confidence interval.
So we plug in the observed μ instead of the p which we don't know
under the Central Limit Theorem, we get the same Gaussian
and then we compute the x which μ-x or μ+x give us these decision boundaries
such as the total area in these two tails over here is exactly 0.05. That's the same as 5%.
In fact, you placed half of this on the left side and half of it on the right side.
When that's the case, the confidence interval itself carries 95% of all possible values for p,
so the chances that p lies outside the green confidence interval is 5%,
hence, we call it a 95% confidence interval.
Let me ask you a quiz. Suppose you go from 95% to 90%,
does this make x smaller, larger, or will there be no change. Which one is it?